this is the third time you're going to
hear about very PB uh and uh so I can
again run through even fewer details
than the previous speakers have because
you're all experts in very PB now so we
are using a proof system for
pseudobillion constraints uh and we have
a verifier program that can verify
proofs written in this system and the
peripherals are based upon cutting
planes now uh for me I'm going to make
use of another peripheral that hasn't
been mentioned yet but it's really just
a kind of syntactic sugar for a set of
cutting plane steps this is the reverse
unit propagation rule I've put unit
propagation in big scare quotes because
this is obviously a generalization of
unit propagation to the pseudobullion
setting so it's not entirely involving
uh units but essentially we can
introduce a clause or I should say a
pseudobillion constraint if the negation
of that constraint unit propagates in
this generalized uh sense to
contradiction on our formula and then we
have more rules where we've heard about
the redundance rule I'm going to just
use this in the sense of an extension
rule like we heard this morning so we
can introduce fresh reified variables so
I don't need the full power of that but
I can use it to implement this extension
Rule and we have dominant installation
rules that you've heard about I'm not
going to
um make use of that in this talk
although it is interesting obviously and
we have uh all these applications for
very PB some of which you've heard about
performing from Mac site certified
symmetry breaking there's also other
things which you haven't heard about uh
we can certify graph algorithms using
very PB we can do search about CNF
translations I think we heard a little
bit about that uh certified parity
reasoning so there's lots of things that
can be done with this proof system and
kind of the question arises can
constraint solving get in on this party
uh and I'm going to argue the answer is
yes so uh what do we need for a
pre-flogging system for constraint
programming well first of all we want
something that's going to be simple for
solver authors to implement and also
expressive enough to capture the kind of
reasoning that we do in constraint
solving so I'm going to focus on the two
big things that kind of make a
constraint solver constraint solver uh
so uh we're we're backed fundamentally
by a backtracking search procedure and
then we take advantage of these
specialized propagation algorithms so
you'll think back to kieran's talk
yesterday and on on how they work so
let's start with the kind of the easy
bit and this is this is going to be
relatively straightforward how can we
pre-flog backtracking search uh making
use of The Cutting points or this
reverse unit propagation rule in a
suitably in setting uh so we're making
guesses and then we're hitting a
contradiction and then we're
backtracking and what we're going to do
to produce a proof of this is anytime we
backtrack we're going to Output the
negation of the series of guesses that
led us to want to backtrack back and
we're going to continue doing this and
we're going to say this follows by
reverse unit propagation because we
contradicted something so at least one
of these guesses can't hold so uh that's
what that says and we continue to do
this for every single backtrack until
eventually we're going to backtrack from
the first variable that we decided to
branch on and we're going to have
eliminated both values we're going to
say it can't be one it can't be zero and
so the problem as a whole is
unsatisfiable and that gives us a
complete providing we log all of these
reverse unit propagation steps in the
same order that we solve them in in our
byte tracking algorithm this is going to
give us a complete proof of the
procedure so that's really
straightforward and at the core of a
constraint solving algorithm is also a
backtracking algorithm so we'd like to
say for our solver authors anytime you
backtrack we want you to Output a rap
statement that is the negation of the
series of guesses up to that point in
the solver and that should be quite
straightforward
um of course this is sudo Boolean proof
vlogging that's been talked about so far
and I'm suddenly telling you I want to
apply this to the Boolean providing to
constraint solving
um so pseudo Boolean we're obviously
dealing with zero one variables
constraint solving we can have these
multi-valued variables with much larger
domains so we're going to have to think
about encoding the problem in some way
and the kind of key point to to think
about here is we're still using our
original solver so we're not encoding
the problem in the sense of Marine's
talk and then solving that encoded
problem we're somehow just using the
encoding for the proof so in this sense
we don't need the propagation strength
of our encoding to be particularly smart
or good we just need the encoding to be
quite obviously correct and so we
understand quite well how to encode CP
problems uh to sat and therefore to to
suitability there's some very obvious
encodings we can use there's the direct
encoding which we introduce our PB
variable for each possible domain value
you and then we enforce a constraints
saying exactly one of these needs to be
true and that's our and PB variable
domain constraint for the CP variable
and we do this for all the variables in
our problem
uh that's fine uh except we need a
single variable for every domain value
and we could potentially have a very
large domain we could have from negative
a thousand to a thousand and that would
be well 2 000 variables in our PB model
which wouldn't be ideal so we can take
um advantage of a more compact encoding
which doesn't have necessarily this
great propagation strength but we encode
instead the bit value and or the the
value represented as a sequence of bits
so we have enough bits to cover this
whole domain and then we constrain that
the two's complement representation of
these bits falls in the range that our
domain is representing and that's
obviously using a logarithmic number of
variables and it's going to save us a
lot and also might make it easier for us
to encode certain CP constraints
um but in general as well like if we I
said before we're going to have this
sequence of guesses uh we might want the
direct encoding as well so it's kind of
a toss-up to think which one should we
choose
um and the good news is we can somewhat
have our kick and eat it here we can use
the logarithmic encoding and then
introduce the bits of the direct
encoding on the fly as and when we need
it using the peripherals and using uh
some reified constraints so
we can reifice to the Boolean
constraints this is pretty
straightforward so like this this is
really just a shorthand uh for obviously
two constraints two implication
constraints either way and this in turn
is just a shorthand for putting a large
enough coefficient on the first value in
the PB constraints so that the rest of
the constraint is either turned on or
off as you would want it and this you
know in vanilla suitability in terms uh
gives you exactly The Logical
implication that you would want but we
can just kind of hide that behind again
some syntactic sugar and say that that
we're introducing a double reified so
the Boolean constraint here so if we
want to introduce the direct encoding on
the Fly what we will do is we will have
so say we want to introduce x equals
three as a direct variable using the
two's complement encoding as a base
encoding we introduce X is greater than
or equal to three then X is greater than
or equal to four and then we make sure
that X is greater than or equal to 4
will propagate X expression or equal to
three we need this when we're excluding
all the main values at the end and
finally we introduce x equal to 3 as
saying greater than 3 and no greater
than or equal to 4. sorry greater than
or equal to three and not greater than
or equal to four so that's how we get um
kind of both encodings as and when we
want them and we can introduce these in
our our model of the problem in our
suitability model or we can introduce
them in the proof as and when we need
them using the redundance or the
extension rule as as I'm using it so so
that's all possible so when we've got
this encoding of variables we can always
just pick the kind of most
straightforward encoding of constraints
uh that we can think of so it's a very
straightforward to do this if we had say
a linear inequality constraints we just
multiply up the uh the bit encodings by
the relevant coefficients and this gives
you the same CP constraint instead of
Boolean form we have an equality
constraint uh we can do this as two
inequalities again so the Boolean and if
we have not equal we can use the the
reification one of these auxiliary
variables we introduce f for not F must
be true and this is just saying a is
greater than b or a is strictly less
than b and again that's that's a not
equals constraint but these are not the
kind of uh constraints that CPU is
famous for it's these uh kind of more
explicit expressive Global constraints
that kind of uh makes CP a useful
Paradigm so you heard a lot yesterday
about the all different constraints and
we can decompose this down if we want
into a click of not equals constraints
um a better way to do it for it turns
out for our pre-logging purposes is to
encode it like this so this is just
saying at most one between these
variables can take each of the possible
values and we already so we have to
introduce these equals variables if
we're using the log encoding and this
gives us a way to encode all difference
and we can proceed through uh all uh
known CP constraints in the in this way
taking uh well-known encodings uh going
for the simplest encoding where possible
because we don't necessarily care about
propagation strength and so once we've
done that we can now tell our our solver
authors hey you can backtrack
um and you can proof log by introducing
or just asking for these equals
variables and then encoding your
sequence of guesses and I've used our
notation there this is obviously just
plus greater than or equal to one every
time we backtrack and you work through
and introduce a rock statement every
time you do that and that is going to
give you just like in the small PB
example this is going to give you a
complete uh proof of a backtracking
procedure for a CP which is nice and
great of course CPU would not be
interesting if all it was was a
backtracking procedure and and all of
the kind of strength comes from these
specialized propagation algorithms and
so what we're going to say is this is
going to be the skeleton if you like of
our proof but we're going to have to
have extra steps in here which justify
the propagation any inferences that are
made by propagation algorithms so
anytime we reverse unit propagate these
backtrack Clauses we're going to
maintain the invariant that anything
that was known to the CP solver at that
point is available through a reverse
unit propagation of the backtrack Clause
at that point and therefore this perfect
skeleton will remain valid even when
when we've cut off parts of the tree via
the smarter CP reasoning so this is what
we're going to focus on now what if
we're going to try and maintain this
invariant how can we actually
do proof logging for these specialized
propagators and this is where the
cutting planes reasoning it there's kind
of a point in using it because with
phones that there's actually some really
nice ways to proof lock these
specialized propagators that might not
have been possible in another proof
system so sticking with the all
different is it's kind of the canonical
example and you'll remember if you were
there from kieran's talk yesterday how
the propagator for all different works
it represents the variables and domains
involved in the constraint as a bar type
graph with the edges for which uh which
values are still involved in each
variable's domain and I'm going to just
focus on the case here with the all
different propagator decides in advance
that we can backtrack early so in this
case it's pretty obvious we've only to
get two values between these three
variables so even though we haven't
assigned all the variables yet we should
be able to turn around and say okay
we're going to backtrack early here
because this is obviously not
satisfiable and so at this point our our
proof uh skeleton that we had before
isn't going to allow us to just adjust
this on reverse unit propagation we're
going to have to add some extra stats so
that that contradiction remains valid
when we have that series of guesses so
um we're going to have to take a look at
what the all different propagator
actually does and then see what steps we
can log as a result of that in order to
get our valid reasoning
um so you'll remember from yesterday uh
the all different constraint is
satisfiable if and only at the maximum
cardinality matching is left saturating
so turning that the other way around
it's going to be not satisfiable if we
have a maximum cardinality matching that
is not left Saturn and this is called a
whole violator it's it's basically just
we have three variables with two values
between them or n variables in general
with fewer than n values between them
this is the thing that tells you that
this is not possible I know really all
different propagation doesn't
necessarily produce this whole violator
by default it's very easy to modify any
standard or different propagator to get
this whole violator out as a kind of
byproduct of the algorithm which turns
out to be really useful because we can
use this to Output proof stats in
cutting planes so the kind of smallest
example we can come up with that's
actually sort of interesting some five
variables five values so
I'll show you what this looks like so
imagine we've got this situation here
we've already made some derivations and
we're going to assume that we've
maintained this invariant thus far that
everything that is already known to the
solver is available on unit propagation
of any backtrack Clause uh so this is
what we know already we know V is less
than or equal to two dot etc etc and
that's what's shown uh in this bipartite
graph so they're all different
constraint then looks at this in fact a
human can look at this quite easily and
say okay these four values here
um not not none of them can connect to
the values four or five so this is going
to be a whole violator because these are
four variables with only three values
between them and the all different
propagator we'll notice this and say
okay contradict we can backtrack here
um the proof needs some help and so
we'll use this whole violator to do the
following so first of all what we'll do
is we'll introduce these drop statements
which are really obviously implied by
our direct encoding in fact if we were
using the direct encoding these would be
here already because they're just saying
that each variable needs to take uh at
least one value and we can reverse unit
propagate them and if we've been
introducing this direct encoding on the
Fly and we'll also have in the model
like I said earlier our encoding of the
all different constraint which will say
at most one a variable can take each of
these values which are the three values
involved in our whole violator here so
we have these obviously we'll have these
for four and five as well but we'll pay
attention to these three which we can
access earlier in the proof and these
four and using the power of cutting
planes we have the power to add so we
will add all of these things up and lots
and lots of things are going to cancel
out so in particular uh all these equal
to to one thing's at the top will
contradict with uh dot contradict cancel
out would be equal to one things here
these ones will cancel with these ones
and we'll eventually get this done here
which is all the things left over now
this is a constraint that we've derived
the assigned cutting planes rules and
then later on when we're backtracking or
immediately when we're backtracking this
will actually allow us to contradict you
know inner proof based on the reasoning
performed by the all different
propagator because we already know all
of these things so we're assuming by our
invariant that these are all available
on uh on reverse unit propagation of the
backtrack which means in particular
because we know that the values four and
five were not involved in our whole set
and
none of these all of these are going to
be zero so we're going to be left with
something that's always going to be
unsatisfiable in this case it's going to
be
um no matter how you set these variables
the most that they could be is uh zero
so they're never going to be greater
than or equal to one so this is going to
give you a contradicting clause and
obviously this is just one example but
you can generalize from this example
that this will always work if you have a
whole violator and you add up these
constraints in this way you're always
going to get something that allows you
to contradict yes
you're trying to prove
it
so it looks like you're trying to kind
of guess a proof of pigeon hope uh right
so here have a pigeon the whole problem
and you say it's very easy to adapt and
get the contradiction so it is it always
easy to uh reproof a pigeon Hall so
we're using the fat the all different
propagator and so in constraint Pro uh
in constraint satisfaction this is kind
of what Kieran was saying yesterday
pigeon holes are easy for constraint
solvers although they're difficult for
sat now because we already know this
whole set because of a constraint
propagator if we had to find this within
our suitability and setting that would
obviously be a difficult problem but
because we have it from the constraint
solver uh we're able to just output this
in our cutting plane step and proved so
thank you uh knowing that there is a
pigeon wholesale okay Hall said that all
give generates you you can produce these
constraints and the derivation
that gives you uh proof yeah so we keep
track and the solver of which line
numbers corresponds to each of these
variable values and then we just output
this whenever they're all different
constraints uh and and there's a
polynomial algorithm for identifying
these these things so that's kind of
what helps us out here in terms of
proving this so yeah this gives us a
proof for pigeons and this is kind of
why we think that cutting planes uh or
very PB proof system over potentially
other proof systems might be the might
be the way to go here amongst all so
this is going to be easy for solver
authors to Output because these are
relatively simple statements uh in
contrast to having to find all these
cutting planes steps yourself or find
something in another proof system and
this was obviously just one propagator
there are many propagation algorithms
for many different constraints
um and the so far the the good news is
that um lots of the commonly used
constraints in CP uh have similarly nice
or even easier ways of profile game them
using a simple cutting plane steps and
reverse unit propagation so these are
all the ones that are done so far these
are all implemented in a prototype
constraint solver at Glasgow that
um we we've shown basically that that
these work uh and that these are good uh
obviously this is so basically I'm going
to kind of end the talk here with sort
of various kind of open questions that
this kind of uh what I'd like to sort of
look at kind of going forward so
obviously we've got these ones and this
is great and this works there are a lot
of CP uh propagation algorithms uh I
think there's more than 400 is the
number that keeps getting thrown around
so kind of my first open question is
this was very nice for these kind of
core constraints that we definitely want
to use is this going to be very nice for
everything and the hypothesis
scientifically is is yes that we think
very PB cutting planes this kind of sits
in the area where it's expressive enough
to get everything that we want but also
simple enough that it's simple to verify
so we're kind of we're hoping that it
operates inside that zone and indeed we
believe that it does we just need to go
ahead and do this for all these
constraints
um
kind of second question is to do with
the encoding so
um I said before we don't really care
about the propagation strength of our
encoding because we're just using them
within the proof uh and not to actually
search for proofs in and of themselves
and however what what smarter encodings
will give us is shorter proofs because
if more things follow on unit
propagation then we don't need to do so
many steps in order for the the reverse
unit propagation of the backtrack Clause
to hold
um and there has been some work done
where certain uh encodings in CNF of CP
constraints on unit propagation uh give
you generalized art consistency and so
do the same reasoning that the CP solver
we did we know we can't do this for all
things so we can't do it for all
different but it does kind of emit this
question of if there does exist a better
encoding should we be using it
um and indeed if we're getting a shorter
proof is that necessarily what we want
so we have a proof trimming uh a
prototypical proof trimming for these
kind of proof at Glasgow one of the
things we're noticing is that short
proofs aren't always necessarily faster
to verify and so somehow these extra
constraints that seem kind of redundant
are are eliminating things when you're a
reverse unit propagating and actually
allowing you to verify faster so this is
kind of a question and I suppose the
other side of this as well is if we're
using a smart encoding where it's maybe
not quite so obvious that it really does
represent the original problem uh it
maybe seems perhaps less legitimate if
we're talking from a verification point
of view because this part of the process
isn't yet formally verified
um I said this what is an encoding
anyway what I really mean is about this
discussion uh just literally just before
the talk is what do we want from an
encoding where we're using that encoding
to log our proof so just saying that
there's a bijection between the solution
sets isn't going to necessarily be
enough because I can present an encoding
of an unsatisfiable problem that is just
the but just the PB constraint that says
false and then I present an empty proof
and this is going to be a valid proof
somehow of that false PB formula but
it's kind of hard to argue that that's a
valid proof of our original CP problem
unless we've encoded it very carefully
so that each CP constraint really does
map to a certain set of PB constraints
and hcp variable maps to a certain set
of PB variables and so that's kind of a
tricky thing to to formalize there's
um some definitions I've seen before
which talk about this the equivalence of
constraints satisfaction problems in
more than a sense of just
um the solutions are bijective and this
paper here still doesn't quite give us
what we want because it still defines
equivalence of all unsatisfiable
problems but it's maybe getting towards
uh what we what we might want so this is
something to think about
um
so yeah I I've changed this to say what
is a proof preserving encoding anyway at
the request of odds so and yeah that's
the same slide so
another thing that's kind of been a
little bit irritating it would be
interesting if anyone has any
theoretical insights on this is uh we're
often relying on things that unit
propagate and are encoding so we've used
this log encoding and we want to say
okay we have activated these constraints
and all these bit values are going to be
set correctly and it's kind of clear to
say that that is going to work and is it
going to unit propagate I mean you can
look at it and we've been doing this
several times we say well it's kind of
going to bounce between the upper and
lower bounds until we get exactly what
we want proving this is an inductive
argument it is true I have a document
where I prove this in excruciating
detail and it's kind of not very
interesting but it's what I would like
to see is is there something about how
constrained these encodings are when we
can say structurally over these what is
going to unit propagate without having
to actually go in and see exactly what
these unit propagation steps are going
to be in every case
um this might be an undecidable problem
or an unsolved problem
or or it might be something that's
already been solved in a different
domain and I just don't uh quite know
how to map it over to this setting so
this is something that I'd be interested
to hear about
um is there something structural we can
identify here that will save paper and
trees or PDF space I guess
um this is the last one's a bit of a
silly one but it was pointed out to me
before that people are quite used to
romp as a concept from sat and and unit
propagation from sat we're now using
Rock in the pseudobullion context and
the name's kind of a little bit no ideal
anymore because we're not really like I
said we're not really talking about
units
um so I would like to maintain This
Acronym wrap because it's all over the
literature but to get it to stand for
something else so if anyone can uh
encapsulate this generalized notion of
unit propagation on suitability
constraints but still get it to stand
for rock that would be excellent and
please tell me I did ask chat GPT
because of course you do and it's
rubbish so like we can clearly do better
than this this you know we can come up
with a better acronym for up my best
idea would be refuted under propagation
or reverse refuted under propagation or
or anyway okay that's that's the end of
my talk so any questions or answers to
my questions would be much appreciated
foreign
does a lot of things it maybe doesn't
find whole set immediately so you're
verifying the results or you're
verifying the executions that every step
that propagate is doing is correct so
super why so we're requiring that every
propagation algorithm has to justify its
own reasoning basically so we're we're
not just proving a particular result
we're proving that this result follows
in the way the solver solved it so by
this particular backtracking and
propagation and so yes I would say we
are pre-logging the process as well but
inside the propagator your liquor or no
all you not all all different
propagations explicitly giving you a
whole set of like you can have a floor
with propagate or something like that
but in the end you have a particular way
that you output so you kind of have a
byproduct of the uh
filtering algorithm that justifies the
pruning or prunes that there is no
solution so right so you're more like uh
verifying the result of the propagation
algorithms rather than every step what's
a propagation algorithm is doing
so uh in a sense yes each propagation
step is the the step that gets proof
long it's not necessarily every
individual thing that the propagator did
in order to do that step but if we
substituted they all different
propagator for a different or different
propagation for example we'd have to
um potentially prolong it differently so
if we just decomposed it into not equals
constraints we would use the way of
propagating not equals for that rather
but we wouldn't still output a whole set
for it because it wouldn't produce that
as part of the propagation process and
so yeah so it's each propagation step
which can happen multiple times at each
node in the backtracking is the is the
step that we want to proof log and we
might do it with several statements or
just one statement depending on so some
propagation steps Follow by just one
drop statement is all you need so table
constraints are like this or several
wrap statements rather than cutting
plane steps thanks
guys
yeah we'll go easy on you
um yeah so I have a question I'm curious
how you decided which constraint
propagators to go after first
uh so I pair personally did not start
this process but I think essentially
it's the ones that you would most want
we're kind of doing it in that in that
sense so it we're starting with okay
what is the absolute minimal set of
constraints that you would want in in
and to be able to call it like a
reasonable constraint solver so that's
kind of where this set of like basic
constraints came from not not so much
these three at the bottom they're kind
of extras like nicer ones but like these
first few are like the core constraints
of any constraint solver worth anything
we should probably be able to support
some version of these and then obviously
when you get into more specialized
applications uh you know you're talking
about scheduling problems are you
talking about something else there's
more specialized constraints so we were
kind of working from the core outwards I
guess into different fields so I
wouldn't say we started with the
constraints that are necessarily the
most easy to proof log although that
might turn out to be the case
hope that answers the question
um so we've done smart table and smart
table allows you to a lot of other
constraints like lexicographic
constraints can be basically represented
as a smart table constraint and so it's
hard to say I when I wrote my research
proposal I said I was going to do three
in my PhD I've done three so maybe over
a year that would take me to 12 by the
end of my PhD but hopefully as we do
more constraints it'll kind of knock off
chunks of these rather than doing one at
a time so maybe by the end of these four
years we'll have them all that would be
nice
that sounds like the hope all right
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
three times
foreign